this morning North Korea has sharply
escalated its con confrontation with the
U.S and its allies with an aggressive
new missile test the country fired a
suspected intermediate range missile
over Japan for the first time in five
years Elizabeth Palmer has more
Coastal communities in Northern Japan
woke up to the sound of sirens and
warnings to prepare to evacuate North
Korea fired the missile from near its
border with China right over Japan it
took 22 minutes to Fly 2 800 miles a
record distance for a North Korean
missile and crash into the sea
Japan's prime minister fumio kishida
condemned the launch it was he said a
reckless Act
the news was big and ominous enough for
a special edition of the yomiyori
newspaper in Tokyo spelling out the
details to startled commuters
analysts believe the missile was likely
the huge Hua song 12 on view in a
military parade in January
and the first since 2017 to be aimed
over Japan that was at the last low
point in North Korean relations just
before President Trump's attempt to
negotiate with the leader Kim Jong-un
so far this time Kim hasn't said a thing
but his message is clear
he is both angered and threatened by
America's growing military alliance with
two of his neighbors in this region
South Korea and Japan for CBS mornings
I'm Elizabeth Palmer in Tokyo